Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and since we
finally learned what all the Marvel TV Shows
are going to be including the Netflix shows
I wanted to do a breakdown of everything.
Agents of SHIELD is also confirmed for Season
2, but I’ll talk about that more in my SHIELD
finale video later today.
If you’re finding me for the first time
every week I do Marvel videos.
I usually try to post them on Tuesdays, depending
on whether or not DC and Warner Brothers drop
bombs.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Now that SHIELD is going on Hiatus future
Tuesdays will be Star Wars and Marvel videos.
Feel free to leave me suggestions for videos
to do.
So here’s what’s coming, you’ve probably
heard about some of this stuff.
Number 1 - Agent Carter.
This fall the Peggy Carter TV Show is premiering.
It’s already been picked up for a half season,
meaning it will get 13 episodes.
They haven’t announced a premiere date.
But I expect it to air alongside Agents Of
SHIELD Season 2.
That premiered at the end of September last
year.
So tentatively plan on it starting sometime
in September.
Haley Atwell is reprising the role from the
Captain America movies too, which is awesome.
In case you haven’t seen it yet.
There was a Marvel One Shot called Peggy Carter
that picked up after the events of the first
Captain America film.
The show takes place in 1946 and she’ll
be going on secret missions for the SSR, that’s
the precursor to SHIELD.
While being a secretary by day.
Apparently they didn’t treat Women so hot
back then.
Howard Stark will be giving her all her missions,
but it hasn’t been confirmed whether Dominic
Cooper will reprise his role or how many episodes
the Howard Stark character will be in.
It sounds like people are expecting him to
come back, but Howard Stark himself to only
be in a couple episodes a season.
It really is just all about the Peggy Carter
character.
It would be like Samuel L. Jackson being on
Agents of SHIELD all the time.
It would steal focus from Clark Gregg and
the rest of the cast.
We’ll probably get to see some cool 1940s
Stark Tech gadgets though.
Maybe even some of the Lola repulsor tech
he showed off in that first Captain America
film.
Moving along to the Netflix Series.
There’s Daredevil, Jessica Jones, Luke Cage
and Iron Fist.
Each of the shows are going to premiere really
close to the same time in 2015.
There’s no official release date for any
of them yet, but expect them to premiere somewhere
near Avengers Age of Ultron which is May 1st
next year.
Each of the four Netflix shows are getting
13 one hour episodes.
Because they’re going to release each of
the shows like House of Cards, you know, dump
all the episodes at once.
They’re writing them to be like 4 different
13 hour movies.
They’re calling it a binge-friendly approach.
But the really cool thing is that each of
the stories in the shows will build up to
an Avengers Style Team up called the Defenders.
That will be a miniseries.
So think of it like a 4 hour Avengers movie.
The stories will all exist inside the shared
Marvel Universe, but they’re going to be
their own separate thing.
Just like Agents Of SHIELD only crossed over
with the movies very briefly.
So we’re not going to see Tony Stark in
any of them or any of the Avengers.
But the events of the shows will influence
what’s going on later on Agents Of SHIELD
and in the movies.
So there will be connective tissue at the
story level.
Personally I’m a little nervous about the
idea of having to binge watch 52 hours of
television.
Since it’s so far off I’m not going to
worry about how I’ll do videos for all those
episodes.
But I will do bonus videos for big announcements,
like when they start casting actors.
That’s one of the big things they have to
do this year.
I wouldn’t be surprised if they announced
who’s playing Daredevil, Jessica Jones,
Luke Cage and Iron Fist at comic con.
Don’t expect it to happen in Hall H though.
Remember, Agents of SHIELD was a whole separate
panel.
And Marvel only has an hour in Hall H to talk
about 4 or 5 movies.
So they’ll probably use one of their TV
panels to talk about the Netflix shows.
It’s really exciting that Marvel and Disney
are willing to produce Netflix content so
I’ll definitely be doing videos once they
start releasing more info.
Based on previous Avengers experience I think
we can plan for each of these different shows
to deal with Origin stories, just like all
the separate Avenges films established those
characters before they did the Avengers Team
Up movie.
So don’t worry if you’ve never read the
comics, the shows will explain everything
you need to know about them.
But the writers are always good about sticking
a bunch of easter eggs in if you are a big
fan of the comics.
They haven’t said if they intend for the
shows to continue and get more than one season,
but if they’re successful I’m sure they’ll
keep making them.
House of Cards was so successful that they
greenlight Season 3 before Season 2 even started.
The real reason Marvel is releasing it all
on Netflix is that there’s a very small
amount of space on television for programming
period.
They’ll have SHIELD season 2 and Agent Carter
on ABC.
That’s a lot of superhero shows for broadcast
tv.
So naturally Netflix with infinite space is
the next best place to put everything.
But now it’s your turn, let me know whether
or not you’re excited to see the new Peggy
Carter tv show and all the Netflix shows.
I am excited to finally see a new female comic
book show.
A lot of the fandom is wondering what that
first female movie is going to be.
Right now the odds are on Black Widow, just
because she’s already been established.
But let me know what you think!
Like I said, there’s a ton of stuff going
on this week.
So be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I also posted a master schedule down in the
description so you know when I’m posting
stuff.
Right now click here for my SHIELD finale
video.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
it.
And click here for my new Justice League video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!